joining me all week is my sister in
beauty hashtag sisters in beauty and
co-founder of milk makeup
zanna roberts rossy hi
how are you oh so good to be back oh my
gosh i'm so happy
we're together i know best week ever
b-w-e
okay in the news your neighborhood
target store
might have a starbucks in it but it's
all about to get a little more company
target just announced
that next year it's installing ulta
shops
inside 100 of their stores of which
there are 1800
with hope to expand also is also
training target employees
in beauty consulting to staff these
shops in a shop
this is not good news in the fact that i
did not need any
more excuses to spend any more time in
target
i'm not just one card there's going to
be two cards maybe three cards following
me around
it's like what are you doing today going
to one place one place for the entire
day
i love when corporations make decisions
like this because it just shows that
anything is possible and it could be
you know something fun like a dorito and
a taco bell or an alternate target but
it makes a huge commerce different it's
interesting business
it's like when you know amazon says
they're going to get into
pharmaceuticals
these decisions affect our lives in our
world and i'm fascinated by business and
i think this is a really interesting
it's changing the face of retail for
sure absolutely in the face of my
shopping expedition where i will be
buying toothpaste beauty leggings
diapers every jacket jacket the whole
lot in one foul swoop
can't wait i love it okay
next step your story all right allah
says you can now get
baby yo baby yoda eyeshadow
and they're absolutely right colourpop's
latest eyeshadow palette gives us brown
green gold and all the shades inspired
by the cutest in the galaxy
i am obsessed my entire family is
obsessed it's quite the
crowd pleaser in the rossi household big
mandalorian fan
huge mandalorian everybody freaks from
mandalorian
2 a.m every night last week watching
mandalorian god i'm late to this party i
really am but
i have to say uh we're going to talk
about this all week collabs really are
the hottest thing
in beauty and especially a star wars one
with colourpop and these green
eyeshadows by the way
for you and me anyone with brown eyes
should invest in a green eyeshadow
absolutely green eyes colourpop makes it
pop it's on colourpop.com all right
next on the news put on some chumbawamba
and break out the jean skorts because
we've got a 90s flashback
fine oh my gosh for some reason that
made me have to get
up and dance
who what where says that after the
fading in the 90s the brown lipstick is
now back here in 2020
this was everywhere i used to rock it
too and now it's been spotted on red
carpets and the lips
of so many stars because if you're
thinking of adopting this look
the undertone is key and picking the
shade of brown that works best for you
at flower beauty we actually test all
the different colors on all different
skin tones
eye color hair color and
multi-generation because then if we send
you out we don't have
you know we're not l'oreal we don't have
47 000 lipsticks i
wish we were um but so we try to make
each one count yeah and each one is
going to suit absolutely everybody
yes i love brown i love the fact that
it's kind of unexpected it's a little
bit grungy yet it's still a little bit
glam
you said before that the red lipstick is
kind of the stiletto
beauty i think the brown lipstick is
like the combat boot
i do you feel i i have tingles
you said combat boot and i literally my
skin tangled because i used to wear
nothing but
combat boots so i'm going to break out
some brown lipstick and some combat
boots in honor of you
and some jeans and some squirts maybe a
gaucho pair
maybe not courtney what do you think
okay
next up npr is reporting that ups
is lifting its ban on beards as well as
natural black hairstyles such as braids
and locks and these changes were made by
carol
tomae the very first female ceo
in ups history my skin really is
tingling now
she wants forever to feel comfortable
genuine and authentic
oh my goodness i love this story i love
this woman
bravo welcome to the 21st century ups
everybody
should be allowed to go to work feeling
authentically themselves not
fear that you might be fired or even
called unprofessional
yes a rock in your natural look and
these are old corporate standards
of presentation that we live in a
different society now
and lately i just love the respect
of this story and the honor and i'm just
so excited well zanna this is such oh
wait hold on really quickly the star
game oh my gosh these these these
tell me everything okay these are
trending not only is it now about
having pimple patches but pimple patches
want to be
seen so these are beautiful little stars
they're by starface
and you can pop them on your pimples and
rock it out okay these are
all the rage even michelle lee the
editor-in-chief of allure beauty
told me this is what she uses and can
you even handle
this packaging if we had pharrell envy
packaging yesterday
i have starface oh it's starface not
stargazer
starface these are hydrostar patches and
they really do bring the pimple out and
in the best way
you know what the next time i get a zit
guess what
i'm gonna starface you so everybody get
your starface and start
enjoying your acne thank you